me Libby and Becky have always been very
close and I found out Libby was pregnant
at the same time the entire world did so
I just feel like at that point like
is that how you feel about us like we're
not anyone special to you to have us
find out the same time as a random Joe
Schmo does you know so it's hurtful like
Libby would not have made that decision
on her own period
well you're becoming stranger more or
more so well that is true and that's not
our fault okay Pamela okay so what next
Pamela yes so now everything that I say
I'm like someone else that you don't get
along with well you're following in
front of me
I feel about the whole roots of these
problems are coming from baby's mother
and Pen she's about one but started Zola
this kind of behavior she is covering up
for Charlie and her daughter is Rebecca
and Jen and they're just following her
lead
and you win
she's your mama's eyes she went to Pam's
birthday party and you go over there now
followers
it's not my problem that her and Libby
and you guys have an issue why is that
my problem you're just followers
a bunch of followers
that you're still holding on to that
if you don't like it
again
five minutes
[Music]